what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time i'm here with
paulina ivaluva marinova pompano p-i-m-p
and she finally has on the right uniform
thank god don't forget that lunch money
is now
sponsored by block five you can earn up
to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account this
is a no-brainer
go check them out at blockfight.com
blockfy.com pump 8.6
apy in an interest-bearing account you
know that i'm an investor a user
a very happy user they also have a
crypto exchange you can get a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
go check them out block five dot com
slash pomp
polina what is up hi guys
u.s unemployment claims held steady at
884
000 last week the labor department
reported
thursday a sign the labor market
recovery is losing steam six months
after the coveted pandemic
claims have fallen from a march peak of
about seven million but remain at
historically high levels
above the pre-pandemic record of 695
000. i love how they talk about it's
holding steady no
almost a million people lost jobs last
week that's what happened almost a
million people lost jobs last week
before 2020 this would have been the
highest week
of unemployment ever on record just to
put it in context
so they say oh it's holding steady no
this would have been
the highest week of unemployment ever
ever
before 2020 in terms of new jobless
claims so
not good also not good is when
it was falling from 6.6 million
6.6 million and it kind of kept going
down down down down down every week
because oh look people the job uh
the rate of job loss is falling well now
it's kind of bottomed
and what we're actually seeing is this
flat line where
every single week now it's around a
million people
are still losing their jobs and so
that's not good
continuing claims continuing claims
increased to about 13.4 million at the
end of august
so the unemployment rate right the first
number we just talked about was the
number of people who lost
their jobs last week was about 850 000
give or take
but the continuing claims people who
lost their jobs in the past
that's actually increasing and so when
it's increasing
that means that unemployment is going up
so remember how everyone was
talking about oh unemployment's
improving no it's not it's going the
opposite direction
it's getting worse data is so misleading
well you can spin the
data is not misleading it's how you spin
the data to make it misleading
well things are misleading up around
here
all right all right what's that what's
next so you know how jc penney went bank
or declared bankruptcy earlier this year
yes were you sad
um no not really so mall
owners simon property group and
brookfield property group have an
agreement to buy jcpenney
out of bankruptcy so simon and
brookfield intend to acquire
substantially all of jcpenney's retail
and operating assets
for 1.75 billion with a combination of
cash and debt this is the best thing to
ever happen to jc
penney that thing was headed for the
drain well no
remember this is the the key here is
bankruptcy does not mean a company goes
away yeah right
what it means is it goes into the
bankruptcy filing process
there is usually a wipeout of equity so
if you held equity previously
it's worth zero there are bondholders
right or debt
um people hold the debt they usually
have some sort of recovery of assets
or they conduct a sale of the assets
which is what's happening here
to recoup some money and now jcpenney
has new ownership
there will be a recapitalization of the
business and they'll be off to the races
and so maybe it's successful maybe it's
not but when people
fear bankruptcy what they don't
understand is
these assets don't disappear right
remember what
we were talking about earlier this year
with the airlines everyone's like oh my
god we can't have the airlines go
bankrupt
yes we can we should have let the
airlines go bankrupt because it would
have taken
bad business owners people who obviously
don't know how to run those businesses
correctly and it would have gotten rid
of those equity holders
and somebody else would have came in
bought the assets and could have
recapitalized the businesses and would
be off to the races
instead what we're getting with the
airlines is all of that aid
that we gave those airlines they're
still firing a third of their
work staff so it says despite
mall owners desires to keep retailers
alive
even if only on life support it's by no
means certain that jc penney will
survive this crisis
pr1 which filed for bankruptcy with the
intention of staying in business is now
in the process of closing all its stores
and going out of business
misleading why because that guy bought
it tai lopez bought pier one
okay they're still going out of business
no they're not going out of business
though they're shutting their stores
because what he did was he bought all
the assets
and the ip and then what he basically
did was he said
i'm not going to assume the physical
retail store leases
okay so these people are looking and
saying oh my god the physical stores are
shutting down
that doesn't mean the business is going
out of business it means that they're
shutting on the physical retail stores
because the person who bought the ip and
the assets
didn't assume the retail leases so they
basically said give me the good parts of
the business i don't want the bad parts
of the business
right what we're watching is we're
watching all kinds of capital markets
activity
play out right now and there's a lot of
people who cover
these types of transactions and they
don't actually understand how the
transactions occur
and therefore there's kind of just these
like very uh
carte blanche is that a part that's the
terminology right
yeah like analysis they just they just
take a paintbrush and they just pin it
across everything
but nuance is very important in this
stuff so pier one is not going out of
business
it's that the retail locations are being
shut down on to tick tock
all right this is your more this is more
your territory that's not really
you she spent an hour last night
watching tick-tock no this is not
about the product itself bite dance is
speaking with the us government about
possible solutions that may allow it to
retain
some ownership of the us operations of
tick tock while satisfying regulators in
both china and the u.s
those possibilities include handing over
operational control of tick-tock data to
a u.s tech company
while potentially still holding on to
some ownership of assets
so china doesn't really want to sell it
it's of course not
why would they well china doesn't get to
sell it
right it's bite dance which is it's
trying to avoid a full
sale which to me sounds like they don't
want to sell it what would you do
if you were bike dance would you just
give the middle finger to the u.s and
say
take us out of the app stores i'd take
all the influencers on tick tock and
bring them over to china
if i was bite dance what does that have
to do with u.s
operations so that i don't care who uses
it in the u.s
as long as i have the american
influencers in china they can use it and
they can keep creating content
oh so you're saying that you would lose
the us users on purpose
and you would take all the influencers
because the content is more important
than the user base
yeah do you know how many people there
are in the rest of the world
true but if india and the u.s
uh ban it then china is definitely
obviously a big market but other than
that
i'd force everybody in china to download
it too okay
you're literally a dictator you don't
want me being the head of bite dance
what would you do i would sell it why
because the geopolitical problem
is uh i think too
great of an obstacle yeah and so
what they should do is they should
basically try to get the absolute best
deal they can get a bunch of cash
maybe even get somehow get some
ownership yeah in the
assets moving forward uh and then just
live to fight another day
what you don't want to do is you don't
want to basically like um
buck up against piss off the u.s the us
government
right because when you do that you're
going to be caught in this geopolitical
uh crosshair and what happens when they
turn and start going after the rest of
your business
so could you could you sell it and then
start
another tick tock like product
i mean you could there's probably it's
hard obviously to build these things
and scale them like this but i also
think that
uh what we're seeing is we're just
seeing that
um you've got to start to think about
country-specific strategies if you're a
business
and so if you're a chinese business
you've got to think about how do i do
us-based things
and so you know you could start uh
something else
in the united states but you have to get
a us-based team you have to have a
complete firewall so it's in the us and
then just use your capital to invest
maybe
right so you own it or own a big part of
it
but you basically build it in a way that
it's siloed from your chinese operations
so that the us government doesn't come
after you well so it says that it's
still unclear if the trump
administration will be willing to go
along with such a
solution in terms of a sale so i mean
i thought trump said he would ban it but
now they're talking about selling it but
it's still unclear even if they
agree to a sale that trump will agree to
it correct i think what they said was
there was a ban on a giant on
transactions with chinese
these very specific chinese companies
and
those transactions would include the app
stores couldn't support
them things like that so it's
effectively a ban but
if a chinese company doesn't own the
assets
then tick tock wouldn't even be in the
crosshairs
right if a u.s company owned it then
that executive order wouldn't apply
so that's the whole idea of selling is
if you sell it to a us-based company
then it can continue to operate because
now it
isn't affected by that executive order
got it all right what's next
one of the winners of the coronavirus
pandemic is
shopify the coronavirus pandemic has
forced many small businesses to finally
open online stores and turn to
e-commerce software provider shopify
into one of the biggest winners of the
retail shakeout
so while all these like physical stores
are trying to figure out what to do in
declaring bankruptcy
the shopify is the platform for these
small businesses
thriving millions of small businesses
have had to adapt to a world where
online sales abruptly jumped to levels
that weren't expected for years
u.s e-commerce sales surged 37 to 200
billion in the second quarter
yeah i mean look shopify's got a
fantastic business i use it i think it's
a great product
i really like shopify ceo i think he's
great toby
and i think he's really thoughtful and i
think that he's doing all the right
things frankly
yeah and the other thing too is all
these small businesses are realizing
like hey we need a digital
strategy right and so it's kind of like
wordpress for those who don't know
shopify is basically like
if you want to blog you used to get a
wordpress right if you want an email
newsletter you get substack if you want
an online store you shop do we know why
they're going to shopify not amazon
for their online presence are they doing
both there's
uh a different type of experience right
so you can go sell
products on amazon amazon's going to
take 40 percent there you don't have
your whole page
yeah well yeah and i think that there's
just a lot of control that you're giving
to amazon
um with shopify shopify basically gives
you the tools
to build your own online store right so
the difference is like do i want to go
sell it on somebody else's store or do i
want my own store
and you could do your own marketing
whereas uh
amazon doesn't allow for that yeah you
owns the the customer relationship i
mean it's very very
do you know what percentage shopify
takes this article doesn't tell me
if i remember correctly i thought it was
only like eight percent it's less i
think it's
less than amazon well it's definitely
less than amazon amazon takes
but whatever percentage it takes a
percentage of every transaction
and its revenue has nearly doubled to
714.3 million in the second quarter
wow yeah it makes a lot of sense that's
wild okay another winner
of the coveted pandemic this one kind of
unexpected
i think the athletic that sports media
site
says it hit a hundred million of wow one
million subscribers
after surviving the sports shutdown how
has the athletic weather this
month's long shutdown and why have
subscribers continued
to pay for its content short answers i
don't know
uh this is very impressive the fact that
they've now hit a million
uh people i think it took them two years
to go from uh you know non-existent to a
hundred thousand subscribers
and then it took them another two years
from a hundred thousand to a million so
obviously they're doing something right
um one of the things that is very
interesting to me is
uh there could be a thesis that because
live sports wasn't happening
people still wanted some sort of sports
content
and therefore they subscribed so it
actually could like have this like weird
effect well because they also do
profiles right they don't only do
like game gamers and people are paying
attention like oh my god sports got
cancelled like when's it coming back
right what's going on with these teams
or
is this gonna happen like there's
definitely a uh
an argument to be made that the shutdown
could drive more interest yeah
rather than less uh because it put more
of a focus
and then also from a macro trend
standpoint people were just sitting at
home they were consuming more content in
general
right and also they had the right
business model so
while other media companies that are ad
based saw their revenue
dip 20 to 40 percent this year the
co-founders of the athletic credit their
subscription-only business model
with keeping the company afloat the
company makes more than 60 million
dollars
in pure subscription revenue and has ad
sales from podcasts that's a lot
yeah i mean that makes sense so i mean
look it it's fantastic that uh that
they're doing well
look i i am a fan of my brothers uh
subscribes
he loves the uh the coverage and so i
think that this makes a lot of sense
they publish 200 articles a day guys
yeah that's wild i mean look it's uh it
makes sense
yet somehow i never see their content
anywhere i know but like are people not
sharing it that kind of sucks
no it's behind a paywall all right
starbucks
let's talk about starbucks it's finally
ditching straws
and ushering in its long-awaited sippy
cup lids
for iced beverages i just i don't like
that the hole is like
not can be mine i get starbucks every
morning you want to see what i do
they said that you can't have a straw i
put the straw right in that little sippy
cup hole
you see that right there that's called
innovation i'm not i'm not
getting rid of these straws well why do
i want to drink it as a little kid
when they get rid of the straws you're
gonna have to i'll bring my own straw
okay i think that's what they want you
to do byos bring your own straw
the straw free lids are anticipated be
fully adopted and company operated in
licensed
starbucks stores in both the united
states and canada by the end of the
month we got to get you one of those uh
permanent straws this is ridiculous the
lids contained roughly nine percent less
plastic than starbucks previous you know
what i said i was like let me solve your
problem for these cups
take the plastic thing off and don't use
it
because i do that i don't need it that
that is
the worst idea i've ever heard you want
them to serve coffee in a cup like this
without a lid yes to everybody yeah why
not
do you realize that they put a lid on it
to prevent it from spilling
spillage i don't care be careful they
have a tray for you
guys polina is very smart pelina has a
lot of great ideas
this is not one of them yes it is is
that a better idea
yeah this is a great idea look how
innovative yeah okay
all right ready ready for my joke leave
a comment
because we'll go read all of them i
promise and i will read them all today
to make sure to make sure we know
shouldn't you have no lid
on your starbucks or not get yourself a
cappuccino take the lid off
or whatever don't have them put the lid
on drink it fast it won't get cold it's
scorching hot anyway um okay wait
i was gonna tell you oh i do read the
comments for that one person who asked
who said i have a very particular look
am i
related to genghis khan or whatever
maybe
genghis khan you know the mongolian uh
emperor the richest man in the world at
one point
she probably was i don't know somebody
asked if you were related to genghis
khan
yeah do i look mongolian maybe you have
some riches buried somewhere that we
should okay
ready for my joke yeah my genghis khan
joke yep
what did the lawyer say when he put his
luggage to sleep
oh i rested my case
i saw it i knew it guys in the last
video he was
over there cheating and stuff i saw you
why did the doctor or what happened when
the doctor told me i was going deaf
it's really hard for you to hear the
news good you read that one too
all right guys that's it for lunch
monday today well while she's trying to
get rich wrestlers trying to get a lunch
money right we'll see you tomorrow
tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends